[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue sur tv
soixante dix huit pour un nouveau numéro
du soixante dix huit sociétés votre
rendez vous hebdomadaire pour débattre
discuter et réfléchir sur les grands
enjeux qui font l'actualité
ce jeudi 8 avril l'assemblée nationale
va examiner une proposition de loi
donnant et garantissant le droit à une
fin de vie libre et choisit alors que
plus de trois mille amendements ont été
déposés majoritairement par les
républicains son examen risquent d'être
difficiles mais aujourd'hui comment se
passe l'accompagnement de la fin de vie
dans les yvelines
on en parle avec nos invités estelle
d'estrées médecin chef de service de
l'unité de soins palliatifs au centre
hospitalier intercommunal de meulan les
mureaux pierre vézy président de la spa
yvin l'association accompagnement en
soins de support et soins palliatifs
dans les yvelines et nathalie charron
vice présidente chargée des relations
avec la soignant et médecin référent de
la sp line
bonsoir à tous les trois bonjour alors
d'après le ministère de la santé
chaque année entre 150 mille et deux
cent mille personnes ont besoin de soins
palliatifs
estelle d'estrées pour bien comprendre
en quoi consistent ces soins palliatifs
et à quel moment ils interviennent alors
les soins palliatifs
une définition qui est assez vague en
fait longtemps été opposé aux soins
curatifs
moi je préférerais qu'on parle de
situation un palliatif de situation du
malade dans les po lesquels il n'y a pas
d'objectif de guérison
vers quel que soit le diagnostic qui a
été fait à un moment donné on ne peut
plus atteindre une guérison
on parle de soins palliatifs cette
passion nécessite des soins globaux
personnalisés
axé sur le confort le traitement des
symptômes sur l'accompagnement de leur
vie qui reste en essayant de placer le
curseur vers la qualité de vie vers le
nom d' acharnement thérapeutique vers le
respect de leurs souhaits en essayant de
pavlov
perdre de chance mais en sachant qu'à un
moment donné va mordre arrivera à cause
de l'évolution de cette maladie
parce que les progrès de la médecine
n'auront pas suffisamment avancée pour
guérir cette maladie
ou alors parce que le patient aura
refusé de prendre ces traitements et de
subir les effets secondaires de ces
traitements
donc voilà c'est des situations qui
peuvent être très complexe mais pour
simplifier il n'y a pas d'objectif de
guérison donc ça peut toucher plein de
maladie dès la naissance à tout moment
de la vie donc vous l'avez dit le but
est d'accompagner ces personnes
comment on soulage dans les soins
palliatifs les patients notamment de la
douleur physique
madoff alors la douleur c'est aussi une
prise en charge qui et qui fait partie
de tout un chacun c'est pas uniquement
soins palliatifs contre est la douleur
ça fait partie des études de médecine
après en fonction du niveau de douleur
du type de douleur on a un arsenal
thérapeutique très très très variés en
soins palliatifs effectivement la
douleur est un petit peu notre pain
quotidien où on essaye de développer
tout un tout une inventivité en
respectant les limites du patient ont
pas ce qu'on va pas toujours vers la
technique vers les médicaments vers les
perfusions les molécules très compliqué
on va aussi vers l'accompagnement
l'écoutent
qu'est ce qu'il ya derrière cette
douleur sous quelle forme elle se
présente à quel moment elle arrive donc
il ya tout un travail d' écoute clinique
d'interrogatoires de soutien avant de
parler de médicaments donc la douleur en
soi est un vrai sujet celle qui est
souvent attachés aux soins palliatifs je
pense que vous faites allusion à la
douleur cancéreuse
lorsque les patients des cancers qui
évolue qui métastases et qui touche des
organes comme les eaux par exemple qui
génère des douleurs très difficile à
corriger à contrôler on a souvent
recours aux cliniques on a souvent
recours à des hospitalisations pour
essayer de traiter souder ses douleurs
de les contrôler
et c'est vrai que la médecine déploie
des techniques parfois précise
d'anésthésie voire de chirurgie pour
essayer de contrôler ses douleurs pour
éviter qu'une souffrance s'installe et
caïn désespoir s'installe aussi donc
l'objectif c'est éviter que ses douleurs
deviennent réfractaires et échappent au
traitement et donc a aussi un soutien
psychologique à la fois de la part des
soignants mais aussi des associations
comme la sp devine donc vous êtes
président pierre vézy votre rôle c'est
surtout d'écouter les patients les
familles et les soignants c'est bien ça
exactement
on est on est une association de
bénévoles de personnes civiles qui sont
formés encadré et qui nous présentons
auprès du malade pour lui proposer un
moment de soutien d' écoute
d'accompagnement ou de présence à son à
son libre souhait et pour le temps qu'il
souhaitera
nous travaillons en équipe pour éviter
le lien qu'ils soient trop étroit avec
avec le malade et notre association
s'occupe donc de recruter de former et
d'encadrer toutes ces équipes auprès des
établissements hospitaliers et nathalie
charron pardon pardon je vous ai coupé
de talisman hospitalier ou à domicile
aussi et donc nathalie charroux vous
êtes médecin référent de la fp been vous
êtes aussi chargé des relations avec les
soignants comment justement votre
association et s'intègre dans tout ce
processus de soin c'est une aide
supplémentaire pour les patients oui
tout à fait donc moi je suis chargé
effectivement
d'intervenir auprès des soignants pour
leur proposer nos équipes de bénévoles
donc l'important c'est que chacun puisse
trouver sa place auprès du auprès du
malade nous comme l'a dit pierre
nous sommes là pour une écoute une
présence pour le malade pour la famille
et aussi pour les soignants surtout dans
cette période difficile de pandémie
parce que et nous on est là vraiment
pour harmoniser pour harmoniser les
soins et pour essayer de soutenir le
malade dans sa souffrance spirituel
c'est une écoute qui est nécessaire
parce que parfois on ne peut pas
forcément se confier à sa famille sur
certains de ses doutes c'est aussi votre
rôle oui oui oui oui elle exactement où
en est on est on sait absolument notre
notre rôle parce que le ce bénévole qui
va se présenter auprès du malade est une
personne qu'il ne connaît pas une
personne qui n'a pas de liens affectifs
étroits qui n'est pas lié dans des
relations familiales des relations de
camaraderie d' donc du coup le malade
est absolument libre de lui dire tout ce
qu'il veut tous qu'ils toutes ces
souffrances toutes ses angoisses et le
bénévole bien sûr et est tenu par un
respect absolu de la confidentialité de
ce qui est échangé loin et donc il ya ce
projet de voir un qui va être en examen
demain à l'assemblée nationale donnant
et garantissant le droit à une fin de
vie libre est choisi nous avons
interrogé nous noté spectateurs avec la
question suivante soins palliatifs et
fin de vie doit tous aller plus loin et
77% des personnes interrogées ont
répondu oui
dans d'autres pays comme la belgique ou
la suisse certains patients peuvent
avoir recours à l'euthanasie
certains souhaiteraient pouvoir
l'appliquer en france qu'est ce que vous
en pensez s'est-elle d'estrées alors en
tant que médecin
tout court qui a prêté serment
d'hippocrate je ne peux que m'indigner
de penser à ce qu'on puisse de légaliser
l'euthanasie en france parce que notre
déontologie nous l'interdît ça n'a rien
à voir avec les convictions personnelles
ou religieuse
les médecins a soumis à cet interdit de
tuer est pour moi le débat autour de
l'euthanasie n'est pas un débat de choix
à ce que quelqu'un qui demande une hta
nazis bas souffrent donc quid du
discernement
lorsqu'on souffre moi je m'interroge
beaucoup sur ce voeu de vouloir abréger
une existence qui est jugée indigne pour
qui cette existence et l indigne jeu
j'ai bien confiance et on croise
beaucoup de malades qui arrivent
certaines extrémités de leur vie où ils
n'ont plus le sens de vip et ils ont des
symptômes insupportable qui sont pas
bien soulagé à tel point qu'ils
attendent la mort pour être soulagé de
leurs symptômes et leurs souffrances
donc il ya beaucoup de demandes
d'euthanasie qui s'origine sur des
douleurs pas contrôlés sur des
vomissements pas contrôlée d'une anxiété
insupportable une gêne respiratoire
donc il ya un travail énorme à faire au
niveau de la médecine au niveau de tous
les praticiens à domicile à l'hôpital
pour éviter que les symptômes de telle
ou telle maladie
desbordes envahissent la personne au
kiel en eau qui savaient qu'ils aient
envie d'en finir pour moi l'euthanasie
une solution de facilité
c'est une solution expéditive ça c'est
pas du tout humain ce n'est pas un soin
ce n'est pas un traitement est une
exécution
donc en tant que médecin on n'a pas
envie de se transformer en exécutant un
grand serial killer ou en vétérinaire
derrière une demande d'euthanasie moi
j'entends une souffrance et donc notre
travail c'est comprendre cette
souffrance l'analyser
essayer d'accompagner la personne ça
veut pas dire qu'on se cache derrière
son petit voie et qu'on se cachait rien
la loi qu'on veut pas entendre la
souffrance
par contre on ne peut pas franchir cet
interdit et on a des solutions pour
accompagner les personnes qui souffrent
en fonction leurs limites en fonction de
notre déontologie en fonction du cadre
de la loi mais l'euthanasie c'est
vraiment une solution qui court circuite
les choses qui court circuite le débat à
quoi bon chercher à soulager une douleur
si on peut juste piqué de malades et
devenir tout puissant à gérer les temps
de nos patients assez pour moi mes mots
une abomination suffisent me permettre
voilà et pierre pardon vous voulez vous
aussi ajouter quelque chose de cerisy
oui j'aurais j'aurais voulu ajouter que
votre allée votre questionnaire est un
peu un peu je dirais imprécis pas ce que
veut dotons aller plus loin bien sûr
qu'on doit aller plus loin encore plus
loin dans les soins palliatifs
de notre côté on voudrait et on pourrait
embaucher ou ou avoir le double de
bénévoles ça ne suffirait pas encore
pour accompagner le nombre de malades
qui font appel à nous et les services
qui font appel à nous donc
allons plus loin oui mais du côté des
soins palliatifs et rejoignez nous
rejoignez les équipes d'accompagnement
nous nous vous attendons nous avons
besoin de vous et c'est une travail qui
est enrichissant pour l'accompagnant qui
remplit de de sérénité et qui apporte
beaucoup beaucoup de choses dans la dans
l'humanité de la vie interne espérés
oui je voulais juste compléter tout
simplement
l'euthanasie n'est pas la solution à la
souffrance et on al impression qu on
nous pousse un petit peu au niveau de la
société au niveau des médecins au niveau
des infirmières à réagir se plier à un
diktat de l'émotion de la peur c'est
vrai qu'il ya des maladies qui font très
peur comme la maladie de charcot c'est
vrai que des des personnes ont été
médiatisés pour aller en belgique ou en
suisse pour mettre fin à leurs jours
c'est des combats que l'on respecte mais
je pense qu'il ya un chemin énorme à
faire pour éviter les personnes de
perdre tout espoir ou deux comme
monsieur point de vouloir médiatiser son
agonie sur facebook cdc des choses qui
sont très intime très personnel la moire
n'appartient pas à la médecine
on peut pas demander à un médecin de
porter la mort ou d'être
instrumentalisés pour permettre à
quelqu'un de mourir la liberté une ex ne
s'est pas donné la mort
d'accord c'est noté qu'est ce qui manque
aujourd'hui alors pour que ce parcours
de fin de vie se passe le mieux possible
puis invasive vous avez parlé de plus de
bénévoles aussi c'est aussi quelque
chose qui manque dans les hôpitaux
docteur d'estrées des plus de soignants
alors oui et en étant salarié du service
public je ne peux pas nier la les
difficultés que l'on rencontre et pour
autant on arrive à faire un excellent
travail
même si on aimerait avoir beaucoup plus
de moyens ça veut dire quoi plus de
moyens c'est plus de médecins plus
infirmée a plus de bénévoles plus d'être
soignants plus de psychologues en plus
d'acteurs de soin palliatif ou juste des
acteurs qui aime travailler dans des
ambiances qui sont chargés d'émotion où
il ya les tic ianu complexité clinique
on se creuse la tête sont sèches ou
essayé de déployer des solutions pour
soulager nos patients
les soins palliatifs c'est la médecine
dans toute sa splendeur on est de vrais
cliniciens en examine les malades on
prend du temps et c'est vrai que pour
les étudiants en médecine pour les
stagiaires c'est un formidable terrain
d'apprentissage donc les formations sont
hyper importante c'est accessible les
soins palliatifs c'est pas quelque chose
d'insurmontable
on arrive à bien maîtriser la douleur
apprendre à utiliser les morphiniques
pour plus avoir peur de prescrire la
morphine prescrire du midazolam
évitez de dédramatiser un petit peu les
choses
le traitement d'une gêne respiratoire
sellam aux-in s'est pas uniquement un
traitement qu'on donne en fin de vie en
phase terminale la médecine souffre
beaucoup de ces raccourcis avec des
médicaments qui sont mal utilisés et le
problème c'est que si on ne connaît pas
bien certaines molécules a évidemment
les symptômes s'installe la souffrance
s'installe et après tout le monde est en
détresse
donc oui le manque de moyens est réelle
mais il ya une vraie volonté de
développer ses moyens il ya un nouveau
plan de développement de soins
palliatifs qui est acquis va aussi
sortir on entend bien que beaucoup ou de
monde sur le plan sociétal et politique
pense que l'euthanasie va régler le
problème du mal mourir en france mais
moi je suis pas du tout d'accord c'est
juste mettre le mouchoir sur un problème
et nier tous les efforts qui sont
déployés
donc les bénévoles on en a besoin parce
qu'ils sont complémentaires pour
soulager les familles accompagner les
patients le fait de écouter un patient
le maître au sens centre de sa prise en
charge de donner le moyen de s'exprimer
dire qu'il veut ce qui veux pas c'est
essentiel trop souvent le patient est
prisonnier pris en otage un un parcours
d'une stratégie de prise en charge et
les soins palliatifs du pal finalement à
s'intégrer à ce que le patient n'arrive
pas à dire quand il a mal quand il y en
a marre qu'on me dire stop à tel ou tel
traitement
donc plus de temps des coûts de
communication
je pense que ça permettrait de
désamorcer des bombes émotionnel de
désamorcer des envies de mourir et
justement pour les soignants qui
interviennent auprès de ses patients ça
peut aussi être difficile
nathalie charron votre association elle
intervient aussi auprès des personnels
présents dans les soins palliatifs vous
le disiez tout à l'heure
oui oui si le personnel soignant le
souhaite on peut effectivement les aider
et les soutenir c'est ce qu'on sait ce
qu'on essaie de faire bien sûr et
dernière question on vit actuellement
depuis un an une crise sanitaire pour
l'association madame charroux et
qu'est-ce que ça engendre
est-ce que vous pouvez toujours aller
sur place ça a été effectivement quand
même un petit peu compliqué au premier
confinement bien c'était un arrêt total
pour les pour les bénévoles puisque nous
n'avions plus le droit ni d'aller à
domicile ni d'aller dans les
établissements donc après on a pu
reprendre et actuellement selon les
établissements
selon à l'importance de la présence de
la maladie au sein d'établissements et
bien certains bénévoles peuvent venir
d'autres non voilà mais en plus quand on
a toujours toujours garder le lien avec
nos soignants avec les établissements on
continue à aller à domicile parce qu'il
ya un vrai besoin à domicile il ya
beaucoup beaucoup de malades chroniques
qui sont à domicile qui sont isolées et
notre présence et je crois vraiment
importante
merci est-ce que vous avez un mot pour
finir pour conclure
bonjour nous les faire passer moi je
dirai juste de d'arrêter d'opposer soins
palliatifs à l'automne asie je pense que
les partisans de l'euthanasie rond ont
un désir que l'on partage c'est ne pas
souffrir et écouter les malins
écoutez leurs souffrances notre but
c'est ne pas nier la souffrance et ne
pas se cacher derrière notre petit doigt
comme je vous disais la sédation
profonde et continue n'est pas une
solution à l'euthanasie c'est un
traitement c'est quelque chose qui se
réfléchit que l'on fait en une petite
sont pas les hâtifs quand c'est
nécessaire mais je crois qu'il ya
beaucoup de pédagogie beaucoup de
dialogues à avoir et beaucoup
d'accompagnement et prendre le temps de
le faire prendre le temps d'écouter la
souffrance avant de se lancer dans des
stratégies thérapeutiques complexe quand
c'est nécessaire on le fait mais des
fois on pense qu'on ne doit on doit
respecter le patient qui veut aucun
traitement aucune perfusion
on le reste est aussi on essaie de
trouver des moyens pour le soulager sans
accélérer sa fin de vie sans la
provoquer sans la ralentir être à son
rythme et pour moi ça c'est digne c'est
respecter la temporalité du patient et
pas lui dire que ma fille finalement la
cie en vie ben il peut aller en suisse
il peut aller en belgique on n'est pas
non plus réfractaires à s'ouvrir sur ce
type de situation il faut informer le
patient être honnête connaître la loi
s'y résoudre mais en même temps ne pas
se fermer à toutes ses questions ses
interrogations
il faut qu'on travaille ensemble qu'on
réfléchisse ensemble mais interdit de
tuer ça c'est notre limite et je pense
que le corps médical derrière moi s'y
accrochera merci une petite petit
dernier mot nathalie sarraute hervé this
moi je dirais simplement que nous notre
rôle en tant qu'association c'est de
promouvoir aussi la culture palliative
et c'est aussi de parler de la mort tout
simplement avec toutes les personnes que
tout que nous rencontrons je crois qu'il
faut que nous parlions de la mort que
nous nous expliquions aussi la fin de
vie
voilà que notre rôle mais aussi il faut
que les bananes parle il faut qu'il
s'exprime bien et on est là pour les
entendre merci beaucoup c'est vous
voulez ajouter quelque chose vous vous
dire qu'au niveau des soins palliatifs
parce que dans le fond au gens au public
de se concilier de chercher des
informations et moi j'ai orage a fouillé
la toile il ya plein de ressources
génial que ce soit des mook des petites
formations comme ça en ligne gratuites
ou des documentaires ou des choses qui
sont en vidéo ou des textes il ya un
centre national la fin de vie sont
palliatifs qui est en train de faire un
travail formidable
la société savante de ce qu'on valait tu
as fait elle aussi mis à disposition pas
mal de choses les associations
d'accompagnement rien à bout tous leurs
sites internet sont des ressources aussi
dans ce sens je trouve qu'il ya un
formidable dynamisme à ce niveau là et
je dois être moderne il faut utiliser
les moyens modernes
après à l'hôpital on est on est plus
tunisien tu utilises vraiment notre
quotidien mais l'extérieur en dehors de
l'hôpital
il faut s'ouvrir à ces questions là
debbagh autour de l'adolescente la
personne âgée a vraiment remis un peu la
mort au centre du débat et je pense
qu'on a de vraies questions à se poser
et sa poupée réorganisation au niveau du
système de santé même un palliatif
on a beaucoup appris de cette crise et
je pense qu'on a encore du chemin
et pour autant
l'euthanasie n'est pas une solution
voilà ce tracé des gens on a bien
compris dans la borne est encombrante
voilà merci beaucoup à vous trois c'est
c'est la fin de cette fille de société
merci de nous avoir suivis rendez vous
la semaine prochaine pour un nouveau
moment d'échangé et de discussion
bonne soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]
où